okay so this episode is going to be kind
of a special one now basically there are
a few things that I need to say so as
you may know I am using my other hats at
because my old hat set is pretty much
broken at this point I can still use it
the microphone still works but the rest
of the handset is entirely broken so I
don't know if I really want to do it so
now I'm using this one but it has a
ground loop so I need to remember to not
raise my hand and make sure that it's
connected to my laptop to eliminate the
ground look it's pretty [ __ ] stupid
I know I need to be less poor and
actually be able to buy stuff and I need
to save up my money and actually buy a
really good microphone that's actually
why I'm planning to do right now I'm
gonna buy like a butte yet a year
something like that and before blue yeti
[ __ ] sucks I don't [ __ ] know one
of those things I'm sorry I just hold
that lag though
but basically what I wanted to do in
this episode is just do some general
planning and I feel like this park is
actually something that I've kind of
getting tired of and I've been noticing
that other people have been getting
tired of this park as well so it's not
really a great situation that we're in
right here and I feel like I just need
to kind of wrap this up so I'm just
going to build around this lake over
here and just see what I can make I
guess I mean the only thing that I
really still want to do is design a
little area over here with the launched
winged rider because I did promise that
I would do a launched intimate and
winged liner so I kind of need to do it
too and I need to finish this area of
course we're just going to take quite a
lot of work but yeah that's pretty much
it now I don't think that I really want
to mess with any terraforming stuff for
anything like that in this particular
area so I'm just going to see if I can
bring down the height of the terrain
over here and it seems like that's gonna
screw everything over beautiful that's
just what I wanted though honestly I
would rather have this because I do need
this to be level anyway so I'm just
gonna replace that later on repair that
and
and I also need to do some more time
lapses with music again I guess I
haven't done that in a while I mean
actually now I come to think about it
I've been doing all of my time lapses
with commentary from now on but I don't
really know what people like more so
it'd be really amazing so if you if you
just if you really love it with
commentary and you think I should keep
doing that well I'd love to have some
feedback on that and if you actually
prefer it with music and be amazing if
you could also leave a comment about
that so just so that I know what people
want to have because it doesn't really
matter to me honestly
I mean commentary takes some more time
but it's also more fun for me and I
don't need to add the things in the
description for the like non copyrighted
music you know in any case I don't even
like the music simply because it's all
that non copyrighted stuff because I
don't want to get a copyright strike but
then again it does kind of take away
from the fun of the video and I could
basically go on a rant about how I
dislike the capitalist system but really
there's no can't really think of
anything better so I'm not going to do
that I'll save you that and this is
basically I'm trying to find a way to
kind of gradually bring that slope down
now it doesn't have a pretty funny shape
though it does also make sense though to
have when the lower area with the lake
yeah I guess I'm going to do it like
this and the way I want to smooth this I
don't know but this should work pretty
well as long as I just keep smoothing it
enough it can always work with path
stuff and yeah I don't know how exactly
I'm going to do those tunnels I'm
probably gonna incorporate some light
some rock work stuff I don't know what
else to do with that of course you need
to kind of mask the fact that the
terraforming over here it's not the best
thing ever especially considering that
there's paths and all that everywhere
which really makes it harder to build
good paths and do good terraforming at
the same time but this should work out
all I really need to do is just create a
general area where you can go down into
the lower area
here and this would actually make for
some nice views it already kind of does
though it's a bit it's too far away
also foliage you really miss that
foliage it's something that I've really
noticed that without foliage a park just
looks so much less good sometimes you're
working on a pike and you're just like
mmm I don't really like the look of this
and then as soon as just yet you
actually do like it so that's just
something that I always noticed I think
I kind of had that with Verona volley oh
no no no no no stop that right there
Oh cond that's also something like it
runs about and I just lifted my arm
Oh oops I'm sorry about the back of
Hercules oh my god that was stupid but
that's pretty much that's also something
that I kind of when people make
mountains and they look like toothpicks
never do that Oh God never do the spiky
spiky mountains always did a nice smooth
and gradual hills mountains hmm right no
this definitely needs somewhere
smoothing over smoothing is also a thing
though like I've seen people over smooth
things like to the point where the hills
don't really look like Hills anymore and
they just look like the land is like
slightly going up and there's no real
here or anything it's really hard to
determine where you have to stop
smoothing and thank you cause some
scenery sets for doing that now watch me
as I try to repair this and it actually
turns or worse actually know how that
worked
thank you don't touch that anymore I
know it's not very smooth over there I'm
just gonna cover with that with actually
I didn't mess things up is that the
thing on the side okay can I get this
right oh whoa oh that that just makes
Metis voice but ah I know that thing is
floating ah why is there not like some
way to fix that oh well it's time to
work on the thing that I actually want
it to
for its the wing Rider now I actually
went into the game oh my god I lift up
my hand again
okay sorry Wow I actually went into the
game and was like okay I'm gonna build
an intimate wing Rider but I didn't even
think of actually installing a Benham I
mean an intimate wing Rider CTR so I
hope that I actually have one that also
looks good
else I probably need to think of
something else or just close the game oh
do whatever I need to do it doesn't seem
like there's anything over here maybe in
the eye section where's the eye any
[ __ ] alphabet there we go oh it seems
like I don't have an intermittent wheel
well I do have this one but honestly it
doesn't look that good I don't know do I
want to go with this one though to be
fair I can always just place one using a
CTR and then at some point if I don't
like it decide to replace it with a
different one so it doesn't really
matter either way what colors do I want
I feel like orange is something I should
try and I'm just gonna make it a station
of about 4h I that's the usual height
and just gonna place it like around here
or something so that I would have a
station over it no actually no that's
too close to a river or lake rather I
kind of want to have a small station
over here and then a plaza of some sort
but I do want to Plaza to be next to the
station and next to the lake so I feel
like this would be a safe distance yeah
and need some breaks Oh though first of
all I kind of went to check like how the
CTR looks yeah there that's that's kind
of the problem it's not the greatest TTR
honestly the seats are pretty good but
the car itself is just no mm how many
cars we want to have on this thing
five is not enough six you probably do
yeah that looks good that looks good I'm
just gonna make this orange not black or
in just a new black and that this should
I've got a lunch section already
oh nice testing thing oh wait I have a
better idea just gonna see if this works
and then at the launch section and of
course I'm gonna raise that lift heel
speed to 90 kilometers an hour
nice come on baby you can do it
oh don't like like that oh that's
actually really nice and really smooth
it's crushed
well obviously now comes the hot part of
course doing that layout mmm I think I'm
just gonna kind of cut out part of this
so see you back in in a little while and
less than one minute went by I just felt
like I'm gonna go into the sky and again
I'm gonna do something like Cheetah Hunt
and then I felt like no I'm just gonna
go down and then do it over banked turn
and now I feel like I actually really
like this element mmm it's pretty funny
also this kind of feels like when I was
building Icarus for Verona Valley when I
just tried to do random things and right
from the start
I got an element that I really liked
sometimes you just have that luck I
guess
now of course finishing this is gonna be
a bit hard don't really know what else
to do with this honestly and this
wouldn't be too smooth honestly so hmm
yeah that would actually pose some
problems plus I'm not gonna do an extra
over-banked turn or anything like that
curve or although mr. game calls them
hmm this is actually hard though
honestly especially with these in-game
tracks building an intimate coast is
always hard because it's hard to make
them smooth and you don't have many
elements to build them with
nah don't want to stay on the same
height all the time
so I felt like going down like that
would have been fun but I can't do that
obviously so I need to come up with
something else
perhaps I can actually go over there but
no I don't feel like doing that maybe
fight no that would just be weird yeah
that's very weird you know what I'm just
gonna kind of see what I can do here and
then come back to you I feel pretty safe
doing this kind of thing I just felt
like I could maybe try adding a little
tunnel or something like that over here
now since this CTR doesn't have any
inversions this version is going to have
to be inversion las' but I might
actually look around and see if there
are other intamin wing riders CTOs that
would actually have a barrel roll
because if I'm not mistaken I would be
able to replace this element with a well
do they call it a zero zero in Barrel in
any case with one of those inversion
thingies so that'd be pretty cool and I
do however feel pretty safe actually
ending the ride at this point without
actually work I'm not sure I'm on a good
height and also though I would have to
make this thing a little longer like
that though it does come awfully close
to the station I feel like that would
actually work it should yeah
hmm I think that's pretty good actually
now the launch section is very big so I
can always move the station around a bit
move it like over here or something like
that feeling like that'd be a pretty
safe thing to do especially considering
the fact that the launch section is very
big and the break section is very small
however I do want to kind of slow it
down so I'm just gonna add these breaks
over here and maybe remove perhaps even
four of these things well I'm gonna
start with three like that and I'm gonna
remove this and put the station here
with that work if you like it'd be
pretty safe now of course I do want to
add the launch section two tiles later
to then and that should work though it
does appear that we have a small launch
section I I can of course add another
one here and that just makes more sense
okay now I kind of need to test it and I
feel like ninety kilometers an hour is a
bit too fast for this so just gonna drag
it down to about that that's probably
still too fast anyway I need to test it
speaking of too fast it doesn't even
make it nice okay this is gonna be 10
kilometers oh that's actually a
beautiful speed Wow I know that actually
looks really smooth speed is pretty much
perfect honestly
well that's very nice and elegant though
I'm not a huge fan of the CTI this
definitely works out though I'm not sure
about using those curves I mean it's not
a very wing writer thing to bang them 90
degrees is it
it's very strange huh I'm just used to
the in terment rack and then adding 90
degree banks simply because it's mean
and blitzes and all that but this would
definitely make more sense now of course
this thing needs to be straight as well
actually saves me some space in a sense
nice and this one needs to be unbanked
as well that's not that shouldn't be too
much of a problem though yeah it doesn't
have that weird banking section here
maybe I should just keep this one with a
full Bank because it would kind of
disrupt the motion of the entire ride
yeah I'm just gonna keep that as a full
Bank don't know you can always do
something with that it's not the only
90-degree bank of course still have
those over banked curves but anyway on
witzger I want to kind of test this
thing from a POV perspective so let's
see do we get on one of the seats no we
don't I went to get on one of the seats
damnit
oh no no no no next camera there we go
oh well that's very smooth not like yeah
there we go that's a nice camera Oh Oh
get out of my face come on don't do that
it's actually pretty nice actually like
the transition off the banks on the wing
Rider cars it's pretty funny I go from
one side to the other
you know it's actually a pretty cool
ride short but good I guess though it is
incredibly short I do like their I do
like the general look of it it's not
really one of my best layouts that I
could honestly just add a little ending
part where I have more curves because he
more I guess I don't know I feel like
this right maybe a bit too small oh damn
I love that first element though and
into that little tunnel thing and
tunnels are awesome to work with
especially scenery wise so that'll be
cool
and of course loads of curves because
everybody loves curves oh that kind of
came out wrong though it also came out
right I don't know but yeah it's uh
pretty decent ride and guess I'm still
not sure about the ending though it
might be a bit too sudden I'm not a fan
of sudden ending endings and this right
is somewhat small though honestly many
intimate launch wing riders are many oh
how many are they the only when I can
think of right away as furious Barco and
that's a very very small ride at least
considering the right time it's
basically a few turns and a zero-g roll
I think and that's it but yeah this kind
of is inspired by furious Barker but
then again it's not but I guess this
fits into the park and scenery wise it
should work as well so I feel pretty
safe just going with this right maybe a
few tweaks but anyway I feel like this
should be good
yeah so thanks for watching guys and see
you on the next episode in which I am
going to do I have no clue well I'm
going to do but it's probably going to
be a time-lapse or maybe a Skype episode
but probably not so I'd say it's
probably going to be time-lapse of me
doing stuff around the park so till then